aber was ich von euch will ist das hier
einfach mal in die kommentare schreibt
was ihr an der hacker schock verändern
würde einfach komplett aus dem bauch
heraus
us kids und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wir spielen heute eine runde
jump league ganz klassisch und ich habe
drei themen die ich mit euch besprechen
möchte und zwar als allererste diesen
link den in der beschreibung habe dazu
habe ich noch gar kein wort verloren
also das erste thema heute soll die dkms
sein das zweite thema wird eine reise
seien dazu werde ich euch heute ein
bisschen was erzählen und das dritte
thema wird die hacker show sein
da habe ich noch eure meinung gefragt
also seid so gut wenn ihr euch für die
hacker schon interessiert dann bleibt am
besten bis zum ende dran denn es ist ein
relativ wichtig aber okay es erstmal zum
ersten thema die dkms also wenn ihr
jetzt mal die beschreibung guckt dann
seht ihr der oberste oder einer der
obersten links führt zur dkms und
daneben steht hier knochenmarkspender
werden das wollte ich nur mal kurz
erläutern ich habe den einfach mal so
kommentarlos in meine beschreibung da
angepackt ohne etwas dazu zu verlieren
und ein paar leute haben sich vielleicht
gefragt hey was soll das bedeuten
ok also die dkms erstmal allgemein ist
die deutsche knochenmark spenderdatei
das ist eine gemeinnützige organisation
also es ist auch kein kompletter die
sowas denken es ist eine gemeinnützige
organisation die sich dem kampf gegen
blutkrebs gewidmet hat und ich bin mit
dieser organisation in kontakt weil ich
selbst ja knochenmark gespendet habe und
diese knochenmarkspende ging dann an
einen blutkrebs patienten und der sinn
daran ist wenn diese blutkrebs bei den
blutkrebs patienten neben der
knochenmarkspende bekommen dann haben
die möglichkeit mit der chemotherapie
vielleicht länger zu überleben das ist
nicht gesichert aber man ermöglicht
menschen dadurch quasi eine chance auf
ein leben und ich denke es gibt wenige
dinge diese unterstützenswert sind wie
das und deswegen ist dieser link jetzt
da oben meiner beschreibung genau weil
ich das selbst unterstütze war ich die
selbst schon kennengelernt habe ich weiß
was die machen und ich habe selbst weil
ich auch schon noch mal gespendet
falls ihr das nicht mitbekommen habt
dann kann ich euch hier mal nein hier
drüben mal da grün
auf der anderen seite meine blogs dazu
verlinken ich habe mich gefragt wie das
aussah als ich ins krankenhaus gegangen
wenn du noch mal gespendet hat okay das
ist die sache und ich möchte einfach
diese organisation unterstützen
und ich finde meine reichweite ist ein
gutes mittel um die aufmerksamkeit für
diese sache und für die anstrengung
unter dkms weiter zu steigern
es kommt dazu auch in den nächsten tagen
noch mal was anderes aber dazu möchte
ich jetzt noch nichts sagen so lass dir
aber überraschend was wenig davor bei
gefallen okay egal dann also wenn ihr
vor allem wenn ihr jetzt 17 jahre alt
seid also mindestens 17 jahre alt müsst
ihr sein und ihr euch vorstellen könnt
leuten mit einer spende zu helfen
dann checkt auf jeden fall mal den link
in der beschreibung ab und lässt euch da
springt überhaupt hin lest euch da mal
ein okay gut zweites thema reise es
zeichnet sich gerade was ab leute und
zwar könnte es durchaus sein dass in den
nächsten tagen in den nächsten tagen
aber ca in relativ genau zwei wochen
eine relativ relativ leise reise
stattfindet und zwar habe ich das schon
mal das thema gesprochen und zwar am
vorgestrigen ist das ein wort ich glaub
nicht also am sonntagabend habe ich das
in der bleibst immer versprochen dass
eventuell diese reise stattfinden könnte
und es ist jetzt nicht so eine pille
palle reise es ist schon ein richtig
dickes ding
und es geht auch richtig richtig richtig
weit weg und es ist auch ein rückgrat
schon sein cooler mensch dabei aber es
ist einfach ein mensch dabei und zwar
und zwar
natürlich ist auch cool also ihr wisst
ja diesen witz und diese reise findet
wahrscheinlich mit lukas stadt ist es
noch nicht sicher ob diese reise
stattfindet deswegen mag ich auch nicht
alles dazu erzählen aber es kann relativ
gut sein und dann dürft ihr euch
wahrscheinlich auf den einen oder
anderen reiseblog von mir und dem ball
freuen aber ich will auch gar nicht zu
viel erzählen weil es ist wirklich nicht
gesichert ich wollte dass nur schon mal
auch für alle leute die jetzt mich nur
auf youtube schon nicht auf tour
einschalten sagen damit auch ihr
bescheid wisst falls da was passiert
habt ihr jetzt schon wenn zumindest
schon mal ein paar grobe vor infos aber
macht man nicht alles zu dem thema sagen
denn ich meine wie doof erst dann wenn
die sache platz um ihr freut euch schon
voll
ich freue mich schon schlimm genug wenn
ich mich freuen es nicht klappt leute
das ist wirklich ein problem ich laufe
immer rückwärts von blöcken runter
dafür muss ich mal kurz die geschichte
unterbrechen ich laufe einfach viel zu
oft rückwärts von brücken runter das
kann einfach nicht sein das ist
irgendwie eine ganz üble angewohnheit
die muss ich mal dringend abstellen
ablegen abgehakt thema mit der
geschichte dann kommen jetzt zum letzten
thema der heutigen sendung sendung ist
eigentlich eine sendung oder doch hin
durchsehen und schreibe es in die
kommentare was ihr denkt ich sehe eine
sendung theorie ist gut okay hier
erstmal durch steppen sehr schön das
macht mir firstrand so thema hacker
schauen was will ich jetzt von euch und
warum habe ich gesagt dass es wichtig
ist eigentlich gar nicht so viel
oder eigentlich doch fehlen aber eine
sache die mir relativ wichtig ist und
zwar würde ich mir von euch erhoffen
roboter vorne kommt wie das ist einer
meiner pass sprünge und würde ich mir
von euch wünschen vielleicht dass ihr
mir ein bisschen feedback zur hacker
schau gibt weil ich habe jetzt ein paar
folgen hacker schon gemacht habe fünf
stück schon das heißt die hacker show
gibt's schon seit das ist krass man die
gez über einem monat seit fünf wochen
gibt es in hackers ja und ich habe das
gefühl das format gibt es seit gestern
so aber was ich von euch will ist das
hier einfach mal in die kommentare
schreibt was ihr an der hacker schock
verändern würde einfach komplett aus dem
bauch heraus
also wer den eindruck habt so da sollten
jetzt 20.000 einsendungen drin
und nicht drei dann schreitet so was in
die kommentare aber versucht natürlich
nach möglichkeit das ernst zu meinen
naja das ist ricky aber damit habe ich
letztens gepackt mit diesem schicksal
bestimmt den sprit und damit die wir
jetzt direkt live ins deathmatch so also
feedback vor allen dingen zu anderen
dingen also außer der zahl der
einsendungen mal die ausgenommen weil
ich mit der zahl der einen seite bin ich
eigentlich ganz zufrieden aber alles was
euch sonst ein feld also sei es ihr
könnt auch das rein schreibens natürlich
kein ding aber das ist vielleicht nicht
so wahrscheinlich dass sich das ändert
aber ansonsten würde ich gerne einfach
mal euer feedback mit einbeziehen zu
diesem thema also fragen was euch in der
hacker software noch stört ist es
vielleicht der kommentar ist deutlich
weniger reden mehr reden
habt ihr einfach mal die gelegenheit da
rein zu schreiben was ihr zum thema
hacker show haltet und was ihr dazu sagt
lernen während dessen versuche ich immer
diese runde mit knackig über die bühne
zu bringen soll nicht klappen kann man
hier unten ist auch eine hey hey du was
kaputt oder frist hat euch direkt man
die angel d'or de weck sehr schön leute
15 kekse man die leute heutzutage auch
immer mehr kriegsende das mal
aufgefallen ist einfach nächste okay der
trick deckel nicht kommt er wieder ein
von hinten macht abstauber lino
natürlich leute zwei machen ab
starterfeld mit gegensatz boxen ein
wahnsinnig okay dafür ist hier in einer
das gut ist und dass vielleicht erst mal
keiner dämlich abstauben kann ja diese
random combos immer oh gott ich weiß
nicht ob es generell 1.8 liegt aber es
war mir sehr rennen vor zack zack zack
ok ja man kriegt habe jetzt einfach so
konnte man sich denkt warum warum ich
warum jetzt warum hier so und jetzt der
auch weg wisst ihr was wir noch würde
sie noch machen können schreibt wir
raten mal wie spielmann ratespiel
schreibt alle mal in die kommentare was
ihr denkt zum thema reisen wohin geht
die reise von luca und mir das könnt ihr
mal die kommentare schreiben
also die eventuelle reise ist nämlich
gesagt die stadt werde so boxens mir als
ob er jetzt den kill bekommen hat hat er
den kick bekommt ja ich bin das ich
würde schon sagen oder rathaus sw bin
ich glaube ich die pvp
um versteckt sich einer das kann ich
überhaupt nicht ab man muss mal kurz
hinterher und ermitteln senior was soll
das hier oben hat sie verstecken sich
die nachbarn angerufen und des weg sehr
schön
jay kay 0 2 hat auch noch ein leben er
hat ein leben ich habe zwei leben ist
eine gute ausgangsposition
er ist mein schwert bitte so ja auch
gott jetzt ja wahrscheinlich ist der da
genau in diesem moment okay das wird
mich mein leben kosten ziemlich sicher
ziemlich save me
der crafter um ein gutes gelingen
abzustauben habe ich feile nicht keine
pfeile leider ja im alter das ist eine
relativ turbulentes deathmatch ja also
noch die letzten worte zum thema helga
show einfach frei von der seele was euch
so einfällt was euch vielleicht an der
hacker schon gefällt und was euch stört
einfach euer feedback würde ich gerne
aufnehmen und einbauen so gut dann ist
das thema auch abgehakt jetzt können uns
voll und ganz der runde widmen habe ich
gerade eben ja schon gemacht ohne es
vorher zu sagen ihr müsst ihr was doch
der weg stimmt ja ich bin halt längst
nicht voll gemacht er keinen sinn jetzt
daran zu gehen
erst mal breaken ich würde ja gerne
kämpft gegen nicht aber ich finde
einfach nicht gefragt man ich muss dir
viel zu viele hits geben dafür dass das
ist für mich lohnt
aber wie macht man das am besten ja ja
super natürlich dann geht ihr immer noch
so eine seltsame combo jetzt bin ich da
jetzt bin ich da jetzt ist sein letztes
leben wegkommt comcom kommt bitte mach
nicht ich andere sachen okay es weg sehr
schön alter der größten gehört na ja da
ist er wieder
ach komm staub noch mehr ab das gibt's
doch nicht
ja was was wie es nicht darum gegangen
also schreiben die kommentare polen
reisen wir und eurem einen sexshop wir
sind zwar nächsten wieder dreimal